A child is showing signs of allergies now
that it's close to summer.
What do you recommend?
So I recommend typically,
so if they're having seasonal allergies like the pollen,
that I just cut the grass today
and I bumped into one of our white pine bridge branches
of the white pine tree.
And the pollen that came off of there
is like, oh my goodness, I wish I were in a video
and it was just amazing.
Seasonal allergies are an issue.
Taking natural antihistamines,
we use our clear hiss junior for kids,
which is fantastic because it's delicious
and it's chewable and it tastes like candy.
So you make sure you keep it in a cupboard
where the kids can attack it
because it tastes kind of like sweethearts.
But clear hiss junior is one of the best ones,
I think, for kids because they'll take it.
And that has corseted in some of the natural antihistamines
type things in it.
For adults, we have a natural clear hiss,
which is similar to that.
We also have our clear histamine scavenger,
which is a little bit different.
So with adults and with kids,
you have to kind of experiment with what nutrients
are gonna be the best for reducing histamine.
The clear histamine scavenger has a lot more in it
that will support all the pathways
and we always just think of histamine,
but there's, oh my goodness,
there's a raccoon at the feeder.
Thank you.
All right.
Live, Conor's clinic, live,
we have a raccoon at my bird feeder.
So clear histamine scavengers,
one of my favorite because it supports more pathways,
than just the histamine pathways.
So you have these inflammatory cytokines
that are flared when you're exposed
to things that are foreign to the body.
So the purpose of these inflammatory cytokines
is to stimulate an immune reaction
if it's something that the body can kill.
So what can the body kill?
So bacteria, fungi, viruses, can the body kill pollen?
Can the body kill pollen?
No.
So then you have another genetic system
that stimulates this anti-histamine type reaction,
which gets rid of histamine in all these other cytokines
and calms that all down.
Well, that gene pathway, the HM and T pathway,
it's not uncommon to have defects,
genetic defects in that pathway.
So it reduces one's ability to get rid of tissue,
histamines, and inflammatory cytokines in tissues,
when it happens.
So that is why, you know, why do some people,
you know, have allergic reactions to pollen
and other people that's bothering them at all?
Why do some people, you know,
have these seasonal allergies and other people's don't?
Well, there can be other reasons.
So it can be histamine overload,
it can be inflammation overload,
so that's a good thing to explore with your child as well.
Do they have food sensitivity?
So they already produce a lot of inflammatory cytokines
and they get reaction to pollen down.
So, okay, is it that?
Is it just overload of inflammation?
Do they have inflammation going on
because, you know,
dies in their foods that they're eating
because they ate a bag of skittles?
And they have food sensitivities
because they're gluten and dairy
and they're exposed to pollen
and now it just tips them over, basically.
So they have this inflammation
that, you know, you're going to the doctor
and taking over the color
and to histamines and such like that.
We're even taking natural antihistamines.
So you're gonna look at these things
digging to the reason why.
So, many times people think,
oh, I just have allergies.
Well, yeah, you do have allergies.
Maybe you have, you know, defects in your H&MT gene
so you don't get rid of histamine very well
that could be possible.
But maybe you wouldn't be tipping over
if you dealt with the food sensitivities,
if you dealt with the reaction
to dies and chemicals and glyphosate
that you're consuming or being exposed to as well.
So it is kind of like a bucket effect.
So the more things that you throw into the bucket,
it's gonna overflow.
So the more things you can empty out of the bucket,
it can reduce your reaction to things
that you thought you were quote, unquote allergic to
like polyds that are environment.
So look at that as well.
But as far as products, those would be the products
that I'd recommend.